Не задля рекорду, а задля практики.  Щодня киянин Ігор відшліфовує своє вміння заряджати та розряджати рушницю.
Робить це, як і прописано в інструкції, холостими патронами.
А от справжніми стріляв півроку тому на навчальному стрільбищі.
У мене були друзі, на яких нападали і вони виходили ледь не з йоршиком захищати себе і родини.
Після цього купували велику ствольну зброю.
Але на мене - ні, не нападали. Я не знаю, як буду себе поводити, тому я тренуюсь.
Як і Ігор, нині кожен українець, який досяг 21-го року, може придбати вогнепальну мисливську гладкоствольну зброю.
А після 25 - мисливську нарізну. Для цього слід пройти відповідні процедури перевірки та отримати дозвіл від МВС.
Таку зброю слід зберігати в сейфі і на вулицю з нею можна виходити лише в чохлі і розібраному вигляді.
Загалом нині усі дії, пов'язані з придбанням, зберіганням чи використанням зброї, регулює наказ МВС,
який фактично не змінювався від 1998 року.
Такою зброєю зможуть користуватись українці. Після прийняття закону про цивільну зброю.
Це пістолет в калібрі 9 на 19, це магазин, тут 9 набоїв.
Він в рази менш травматичний ніж автомат Калашникова,
який зараз дозволено до продажу, чи ніж помпові рушниці 12 калібру.
Коштує такий пістолет від 500 доларів. Подібну зброю, за бажанням, могли б використовувати для самозахисту українці.
Її легко сховати в кишеню і в разі нападу -  застосувати.
Та це все гіпотетичні роздуми, адже для цивільної людини ця зброя залишається недоступною.
За 29 років незалежності в Україні все ще не ухвалили закон про обіг бойової зброї.
Лише МВС разом із іншими держструктурами, такими як Офіс Президента, СБУ та Міноборони, вирішують,
хто зможе отримати бойовий пістолет як нагороду.
Скільки такої зброї було роздано, намагався з'ясувати адвокат Юрій Мінкін.
Як виявилось, чи це була відписка чи правда, але МВС за весь час свого існування не веде єдиного реєстру,
куди були б включені всі власники нагородної зброї.
А у нас і колишнього прем'єра нагородили кулеметом, це така в нього нагородна зброя.
Автоматами нагороджують, пістолетами. Ситуація досить дивна.
На сьогодні у Верховній Раді обговорюють два законопроєкти про зброю.
Обидва розподіляють її за категоріями та вводять вікові обмеження для володіння пістолетами,
запроваджують для цивільних громадян посвідчення власників зброї та техпаспорт.
Крім того, обидва законопроєкти передбачають, що придбати бойовий пістолет зможуть лише після навчальних курсів
та й то, лише ті, хто має 5-річний стаж володіння іншою зброєю. Наприклад, мисливською рушницею.
Втім, мають законопроєкти і ключові відмінності.
Так закон, ініційований депутатами фракції "Слуга народу", виступає за заборону носити вогнепальну зброю на вулиці.
Зброя вдома. Протягом, двох, трьох чи п'яти років.
Ми доводимо суспільству, що кількість злочинів з використанням короткостволу не збільшилась, а навпаки - зменшилась.
І якщо протягом двох років ми зможемо суспільству довести, що зброя це не не так страшно
і суспільство готове для носіння, тоді давайте зробимо носіння.
Автор альтернативного законопроєкту Андрій Шараськін, депутат від партії "Голос",
а в минулому учасник АТО та відомий кіборг з позивним "Богема", думає інакше.
90% наших громадян вважають, що піддаються небезпеці на вулиці.
І тут же, на вулиці, їм заборонено захищати себе зі зброєю.
Тобто після ухвалення такого проєкту закону ситуація не покращиться, а закон має її покращити.
Окрім цього, не збігається думка законотворців і в тому, хто має вести реєстр власників зброї.
Прихильники альтернативного законопроєкту хочуть передати ці повноваження до Мін'юсту.
"Слуги народу" хочуть, аби реєстр залишився в МВС.
Це не зобов'язання мін'юсту відповідно до їх положень, які регулюють діяльність мін'юсту.
Воно жодним чином не має жодного відношення до картотеки куль і гільзотеки.
Це все належить МВС, і ця база має невід'ємно бути пов'язана з реєстром зброї.
На сьогодні Міністерство отримує більшість реєстрів, речових прав, судових рішень. І багато іншого.
Казати, що у мін'юста немає досвіду ведення таких регістрів - це маячня,  бо такі реєстри мін'юст підтримує багато років.
І мін'юст - не зацікавлена особа. Тобто навіть при всьому бажанні чиновник мін'юсту не може торгувати дозволами
і торгувати внесенням записів -  йому не цікаво. Це антикорупційна гарантія.
Розподіл функції між МВС і мін'юстом підтримує і Українська асоціація власників зброї.
Її голова, Георгій Учайкін, вже понад 12 років лобіює ухвалення закону про обіг зброї.
Його петиції з вимогою законодавчо врегулювати обіг зброї як до екс-президента Петра Порошенка,
так і до нинішнього Володимира Зеленського набрали необхідні 25 тисяч голосів.
Втім, обидва глави держави такий закон назвали передчасним.
Звернути увагу на країни Балтії, це найпростіший варіант, вони разом з нами у радянському таборі, і в 1994 році оформили закон.
Нормально увійшли в ЄС, узгодили норми цих законів з європейською директивою.
Чехія має найкращий закон в Європі. Там дуже розвивається зброярська галузь і спорт, і все добре з самозахистом людей.
За даними МВС за останні 5 років 35 тисяч українців загинули внаслідок умисного вбивства.
Більшість  - через нанесення умисних тяжких тілесних ушкоджень.
Через вогнепальну зброю - трохи більше 1%, і лише половина від цієї кількості - із застосуванням зареєстрованої вогнепальної зброї.
Утім, результати опитувань соціологічної групи "Рейтинг" свідчать,
що українці у своїй більшості поки з недовірою ставляться до подібних законодавчих змін.
Лише 23% опитаних підтримують право на приватне володіння вогнепальною зброєю.
Настрої ж тих, з ким DW поспілкувалася на вулицях Києва, дещо інші.
Це одна зі свобод, свобода захищати себе.
Треба, але не в тому вигляді, в якому ВР хоче прийняти. Суттєво обмежує використання зброї.
Наприклад, вам дозволять купувати мобільний, але скажуть, користуйтесь ним тільки вдома.
Тому він не довершений і не вартий того, щоб його приймати.
У злочинців і так уже є зброя, а закон - він для законослухняних громадян, злочинцям він не потрібен.
Можливо, якось обмежувати якимось звітами, контролювати, але людина має мати право на свою безпеку.
Звичайно, да, і використати за необхідністю.
Я думаю, що так, я б сама собі купила. Ситуації різні бувають. І собаки нападають.
Звичайно, пройти психолога і психіатра, адже неадекватних в країні вистачає.
Ні, я думаю, що ні. Це жорстоко і не потрібно. Я думаю, що ми це вже переросли.
Стан самозахисту, коли треба вбивати одне одного - це звучить надто архаїчно і жорстоко.
Свою гвинтівку Ігор придбав десять місяців тому.
Чоловік боявся, що економічна криза, пов'язана з карантином, призведе до збільшення пограбувань.
Живе він за містом, тож якщо непрохані гості прийдуть в його приватний будинок,
він зможе себе захистити до приїзду поліцейського патруля.
Зброю куплять тільки ті люди, які це хочуть зробити, у яких є гроші і які є адекватні до того, щоб нею володіти.
Ось і все, що зробить закон, якщо він буде правильно прийнятий.
Ігор хотів би, аби таке ж право на самозахист він, як і решта українців, мали і на вулиці.
Втім, схоже, що закон знову відкладуть у довгий ящик.
Депутати як основного, так і альтернативного законопроєкту говорять, що наразі голосів у Верховній Раді
бракує навіть для того, аби включити його в порядок денний.